[Music]
87% of Americans think it's appropriate
to require physically able people to
seek work in order to receive public
benefits and generally most government
aid recipients do yet critics call work
requirements for safety net programs
cruel believing they punish people for
being poor the truth is work
requirements are not punishment they
ensure that people who are capable of
work stay connected to the labour market
most states do this with people
receiving unemployment compensation and
they should be doing it with safety net
programs too requiring work sends a
clear message that if you can work you
should be working well government
assistance is there to support you it
also fulfills a kind of social contract
that most poor people agree with in a
poll conducted in 2016
eight of ten Americans in poverty agreed
with work requirements most of all work
requirements improve the integrity of
our safety net programs anti-poverty
programs do much better when they are
perceived as a way to help people move
out of poverty through work rather than
simply a means to make unemployment more
tolerable what do you think about
requiring people to work in exchange for
public benefits let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI